[Music]
let's go to Little Rock and talk to Dear
Marie what's up
Marie hi Dr John how are you party and
what are you up to oh live in the dream
sometimes it's a nightmare anytime
somebody says live in the dream their
life is terrible what's
up well I'll just get straight to my
question um I wanted to know is it
unreasonable to want your spouse to be
your best friend and
Confidant um it depends on your
definition of best
friend well um my spouse basically asked
me to not talk about my work anymore um
I'm sorry I'm really nervous I'm shaking
a m don't be nervous Marie I'm terrible
at this we're you're
fine um he said it's all we talk about
and all he hears all day is complaining
from his work so the last thing he wants
to hear when he gets home is more
complaining or
excuses um kind of to explain our life
he is he has a very inflexible schedule
that is shift work I work for a small
family-owned accounting firm so I have
flexibility which is one of the reasons
why I started working for it because
we're raising two kids
um but there's constant deadlines and
I'm managing you know a couple of people
and so when I leave or have the
flexibility um I still have to get the
work done whereas I imagine with his
work when the shift is over somebody
else is taking over that shift and
continuing the work it's not really like
that with my job
unfortunately um but I'm thankful for it
because I enjoy it and like I said it
allows me to do things like today right
before this call I had to run back and
get a lunch for somebody who forgot it
at home um
and honestly I think a lot of times
whenever I complain it's just hoping for
some compassion so that whenever I do
have to work night or weekend it's a
little bit better received yeah I don't
know
so I might be manipulation no I mean
what what you're mentioning now what
you're talking about now is is not at
all how I would Define best friend cuz
with your definition what you're hoping
your best friend is is a trash
can for you to come empty all the crap
that happened to you today into a can
into a person and you want them just to
hear you and take it but I don't think
that's what you want you said it
perfectly I want some compassion I want
someone to see all of me both the
beautiful me that's the wife both both
like the Romantic partner the the um
awesome Mom side of me and like the
exhausted side because I'm busting my
butt too it just looks different than
the way you're busting it your butt and
that's not about being best friends and
that's not even coming home and vomiting
on
somebody
um it's really about two things one
creating boundaries about work from home
like and what a lot of us do when we
have work at home we bring the work home
we're mad that the work is there and
then we're mad at the rest of our family
for not realizing that I'm still at work
even though I'm at home the whole thing
just gets messy right right it's
different than saying from 5 o'l until 8
o' I'm going to be I'm gonna have my mom
hat on and wife hat on and then I'm
taking that hat off and then from 8:00
till to 11: p.m. I'm going to be an
employee because that's that's the
arrangement I have that's what I have to
do right now for my particular job in
this particular moment and it allows you
to say I'm I'm code switching here here
but I'm I'm a mom here and I'm I'm at
home here it's when you plop up with the
laptop and everyone's watching TV and
you're like hey y' be quiet I can't
figure this out or I'm not getting you a
snack it's you're trying to do both at
the same time and it never works that's
the first one the second thing is is
there's something deeper going on in
your marriage tell me about
that because what you just the picture
you just painted is very much a symptom
not the root
cause you and your husband are pretty
far apart
huh I mean I think so we we have been
through
counseling and there have been
improvements but there still just seems
to be a disconnect like I don't know I
just feel like I'm constantly
criticized and when I say that to him he
says well you're just misinterpreting
how I'm saying it don't listen to the
way that I'm saying it listen to my
words but it
feels not
supportive have you told him explicitly
the words that are helpful and the words
that are not
helpful
um because a lot of times we want our
spouses to be mind
readers yes which is what he tells me
all the time I can't be a mind reader
but I do feel like whenever I have it's
hard for me to
express how I'm feeling really why is
why why why is that is he not
safe or is that a skill you need to
learn because list I think a little bit
of both I mean he so before we got
married before he was diagnosed with um
add which you know once he got some help
for that that did help with some anger
but um
I I would say that sometimes I don't
feel emotionally safe
okay um what what does that
mean I I don't hear this at all I don't
hear this at all like you're talking bad
about him what I here is you're speaking
Italian he's speaking Spanish and he's
trying to tell you as loudly as he can I
love you and you don't understand what
he's saying and and vice
versa that's probably true if he's going
to counseling with you and he's trying
to tell you hey just listen to what I'm
saying and don't interpret my body
language or this um then that sounds
like a guy who's trying and on the other
side of that um you have to take
ownership
of what you need from him and you have
to say those things out loud for
instance in a very similar situation
years ago with my wife I had to say I
just need you to say the words I'm proud
of you thank you for working so hard and
she said in a in a roundabout ways like
all of your laundry just magically
appears in the thing and your kids
lunches are magically made and I you
know like go on dates with you and fill
in the blank all these things and I'm
like I know and behaviors of language
that's like one of my core saying and I
get it would you just say those words
for
me and then she said absolutely yes and
I was ashamed and I was embarrassed to
say something like that out loud but it
needed to be said because I was just
getting frustrated at ated that she
never acknowledges
me and so similarly I tell you that
about my life to tell you you're going
to have to be explicit this isn't
Hollywood and not every romantic comedy
I mean every romantic mood doesn't end
with like I can I I know what you're
thinking and saying it's going to take
you sitting down and saying when you say
these two things I shut
down and it's my nervous system that
leaves the building goes to fight ORF
flight and then I'm trying to recover I
can't be in relationship with you
when you say why don't you I'm
out that's why on this show and and so I
could get all nerded out and talk about
the nervous system all I don't think
that's as instructive as saying that's
why I'm always on the show telling
people look at your romantic partner in
the morning hold their hand and ask the
question how can I love you
today and if your husband asked you that
on a random Tuesday and you knew you had
six hours of work after you got home
that night you could say tonight's going
to be chaos for me would you take bed
times and take the kids out to dinner
somewhere even though we can't afford it
we take the kids out to dinner will you
do bed times so I can fully plug into
this stuff so that I can be fully
present the rest of the
week that's a different request how can
I love you today and that's a different
full expression of what I need and what
I what I and want today um or how can I
love you today I'm feeling super
disconnected can we plan a super like
wallpaper coming off the walls sex night
tonight and we just text each other all
day about it got it right like let's be
super intentional about what we need and
let's have those conversations on the
front end and then give each other a
chance to show up because then if he
says I ain't doing that I ain't doing
bedtime tonight that's your fault for
working late well now you realize you
got a bigger issue in your
marriage and I think that has been the
response not I mean there have been
times when yes he's responded that way
but other times like he'll say well I
was already planning to do
this or you know I think when I have
tried to communicate in the past it just
hasn't been received well or you
know and and I think he is trying um so
I think two things can solve some of
that one is insane
clarity no nothing left to guess the
chance okay my wife will tell me and if
you Google ADHD my picture comes up
right I'm a poster child she will say
Josephine needs to be in bed by
7:45 Hank has this assignment and like
it's very clear and for years she
thought a real invested dad would know
these things would know what time
bedtime is and would know what time
whatever and as part of our rebuilding
the marriage from the floor up it was
hey dude I'm working so crazy I'm
disconnected from the operation of this
house that's on me and you and I have
never sat down and talked about what's
the best bed times for x and for y and
for Z and so I honestly don't know and
so I'm not trying to be a jerk I'm not
trying to be absent I don't know and she
was like oh my gosh I've been holding
you accountable for things you didn't
even
know and then here we go right so there
has to be insane Clarity and there's a
difference between coming home at 5:00
and being like I got a crazy night
tonight I need you to do bedtime and
whatever and him like dude I've already
told everybody that I'm coming over for
whatever and a Sunday night hey can we
do calendar tonight for the
week I'm pretty sure I'm gonna have a a
Bonkers week on Monday or
Tuesday or Monday Tuesday and Wednesday
I'm gonna need you this
week so is it's clear as possible and as
uiver as possible or two huge helps
there and then the final one is life
happens and adults have to be adults
there's going to be days you get
hammered with a project at noon due the
next day and he's going to have to just
suck it up and be a grown man and say I
love you and I love my kids and I love
our family system more than whatever I
think I'm G to go
do does that make sense yes it
does and I think I think
I knew I think I know this stuff but
sometimes it's application and head
knowledge versus heart knowledge it's
hard to it's so hard it's so hard Marie
and can I tell you it's so
unsexy it's so not how the movies are
right it's just not it's like you text
him like I have to work late and he's
like aha I'm gonna get candles and
dinner and the kids are magically going
to brush their teeth on their own like
it's just not how it works right because
he's working a shift and he's like okay
got it and he's on you got a boss
screaming at him and he's got whatever
and the insurance is due today and he's
got to get the oil changed like it's
just life is bananas outside of a
Hollywood
Theater right and most couples are
frustrated by putting sex on the
calendar most couples are frustrated
that they have to look at their romantic
partner the person they've made a human
with and say hey when you say these two
things I'm out my body shuts off I don't
I wish it didn't but it just
does a better way to ask me is fill in
the blank this this clear
clearly
and if you are very clear and you move
up River and he goes I ain't doing that
really hanging with my
boys your marriage is in trouble you
have a bigger issue that you got to face
head on you got to choose reality in
that
moment if you're working a flexible job
and the flexibility comes at a cost
which is boundaries one of the things
that people learned when um we everybody
was working from home home was that they
never got to go home from work and so we
saw these
astonishing people logged in working 17
hours a day because have anything else
to do and we've slowly seen a
productivity decline because working
more doesn't mean working more working
more doesn't mean working effectively or
with good good stuff and so it may be
that this flexible job is super cool and
your kids if they forget their lunch
they forget their lunch and they'll they
won't forget it twice unless mom comes
and takes it to them every time and the
flexibility might be coming at a cost of
the peace inside you inside your home
and so maybe something to look into um
but let's go with Clarity and let's go
with way way way
Upstream let's start there and see if
you can challenge him to meet your needs
that are very very clear and by the way
ask him how can I love you this week
what he might say I really need to go be
with the boys for a night awesome go
knock it out man go have fun have the
time of your life cuz if he goes out and
hangs out and goes and plays softball or
goes and does whatever he does and long
as long as it's not fantasy sports no
fantasy sports um or like Ben Pokemon
Card Collector you can do that because
those got a big Roi on them but like
whatever it is just you're going to get
a better version of your husband if he
goes out and hangs out with his friends
unless those friends are idiots and then
that's a whole other conversation but
you know where I'm
going start with Clarity Clarity Clarity
clarity
start a Sunday night hey can we go over
the calendar this week what most couples
find is it's pretty much like foreplay
with gasoline on the fire when you talk
about your calendars together
whoa